so that's me playing that there's a game
that this is my talent there's a guy who
entry all for people who out there who
are from Montreal let me know if you
know this guy in front of oval D's in
Montreal he would play the spoons but I
don't even think he was a poor street
performer but he would play the spoons
in front overlays a big department store
Montreal and it was I think the guy was
was a local treasure so this is my
commentator but it's totally irrelevant
to start the video off this way this is
the last video I think I'm uploading for
the year before our big livestream
tomorrow
that's tomorrow the Christmas show 8
p.m. Eastern it's in front of a live
audience in Dallas Texas so if you want
to be a part of that I think tickets are
$30 each proceeds going to Christmas
charity and we're gonna discount for
people can join up at Mudd Club and the
portion of those Mudd Club
signups will also be going to I think
Christmas baskets I'm not entirely sure
the charity I don't have any information
in front of me but it is Dallas Texas
Wednesday December 18th
8 p.m. Eastern so 7 p.m. central for
people who are actually going to be out
in Dallas Texas and that will be a
Christmas variety show you know what it
was three years ago I was waterboarded
by Tim Kennedy as part of a Christmas
telephone two years ago I did a 16 hour
CNN livestream and I didn't want to do
that again oh did you run out of peanut
butter
which is crazy about people what did you
dig a hole look at this she dug a hole
look Betty she dug a hole outside and
got filthy I guess I just noticed anyway
three green Wednesday by the way
Wednesday December 18 as a let me let
this little [ __ ] the second I come in
the video she says no you know what I'm
not gonna stick around the clumpy nut
butter by the way if anyone knows any
indestructible dog toys um apparently
his definition doesn't fit but they
she's destroyed every single
indestructible dog toy that we've ever
purchased so if you want to become a
sponsor
take the test we'd be more than happy to
welcome you December 18 let me get back
I didn't want to be waterboarded are
doing
sixteen our CNN livestream so we're
doing a Christmas variety show musical
performances surprise guests it'll be a
lot of fun tomorrow and the reason we're
doing it Wednesday is because there's
the bait Thursday and a Star Wars
release as I understand it I'll get to
that in a second please hold your
comments hold your comments
Star Wars folks I'm going to explain my
position you may not like it but just
hear me out and I know you probably
won't December 18th anyways Wednesday
p.m. Eastern a big break starts it okay
so Star Wars I have to go see Star Wars
with my nephew
I'm trying this okay let me know what
you guys think about Star Wars I know
you know what I know there's gonna be
two categories people who love it and
then people who really love it and
nobody some people who hate Star Wars
are afraid to speak out and I know now
people can speak out of like oh the SJW
element of Star Wars list that isn't
nothing to do with that people ask
sometimes why don't cover that more I
don't really care about it all that much
so let me explain to you my thoughts on
star please let me explain I'm trying to
be careful I'm trying to be more careful
here in then in dealing with gender just
for Hannah because I'm worried that
people will misconstrue this I as it
relates to Star Wars when the show is
tomorrow December your teeth Wednesday
at 8 p.m. Eastern I'm not a fan now I
don't hate Star Wars but I think what I
dislike most about Star Wars is people
talking about like it's just saying in a
binary with Star Wars people do
categorize you as either you love Star
Wars you appreciate it or you don't get
it may I be clear I don't hate Star Wars
but I get it I understand it and I still
don't love it I still don't think that
it's great um here's the thing what
really value about the Star Wars
mentioned they get all upset and I think
that when they get indignant and Johnny
glued is filming this right now I can
cease cracking a smile because he knows
the kind of absolute hell fire that is
going to rain down upon me for daring to
speak out against it must be added in
stores but people get really upset if
you just say listen come on you're
getting upset about Star Wars now the
changes to the
series episode 1 2 2 & 3 and everyone
kind of now unilaterally agrees that
those were not great films and the newer
Star Wars are okay but not necessarily
I've seen all of them there was one more
recently that I liked I don't remember
which one it was because they kind of
all bleed together but what bothers me
is people who get upset at the newer
Star Wars films because they're like
well it's been Kida fied it's been turn
it's been turned into really just a
commercial opportunity to try and get to
Chinese markets it's a it's a licensing
play it was always for kids Star Wars
that's the thing and it's okay it's okay
they they're fun movies for kids but I
always thought it was fun when people
like I can't
can you believe what they did with Star
Wars and Jar Jar Binks is rated on me
Jar Jar Binks it's racist and it's just
and it's now it's gone so far they're
trying to turn this into a Nickelodeon
show I'm gonna monitor did you see the
dancing he walks and they go that's a
third Star Wars that was before that was
but that was once it got commercialized
okay let's go back to the very first one
where half of the story is explained in
writing I mean that to me is the
equivalent of just sort of going back
and explaining away something that
doesn't make sense in the film like it's
like die hard whatever writing the
script as they were shooting the film
and then you go back and watch die hard
there's a documentary about of some
Netflix right now the films that made us
where they hide an ambulance in a truck
but there's a shot where the ambulance
isn't in the truck and so they tried to
fix it with some line of dialogue that
got cut that's what you're doing with
the start of all the Star Wars films
like hey by the way here's the backstory
we ran out of budget we had to spend it
on figurines and bobblehead dolls I'm
not saying that there's nothing good
about Star Wars to understand the
special effects for their time and I
understand that you know it has all of
this this this deep meaning to a lot and
energy that means a lot to people so I'm
not trying to take that away from you I
just do find it a little bit irritating
when fans tell you that you don't get it
if you don't like Star Wars and then
[ __ ] about it now being for kids will
go back to the very first one was the
episode four it's a bear with the bow
and arrow and could you keep going
across space and I think the film didn't
end with Darth Vader blowing
for children it's a film that was maybe
not as key and I and the way I look at
it is you know the first don't don't
like it return the Jedi do not like it
brush like decent film you know kids
movie family-friendly decent movie I
don't think that it's it's it's
groundbreaking and there's no one they
rereleased the story you remember that
Johnny when they released the Star Wars
in theaters the original ones and people
were really really upset that George
Lucas added some CGI to it and it made
the film worse and they felt like it had
been you know they've been robbed of
their childhood
it is his film he does have the right to
do with it what he wants and you did put
all of your hopes and dreams in the
hands of the guy who did Howard the Duck
like this is not a guy who did any other
good films really the closest is
American Graffiti and at best it's
passable so my boys he didn't have a
track record of making good films people
complain about the new Star Wars films
where George Lucas had more of a hand in
it and they really only like the Star
Wars overture Lucas didn't have any hand
in it but he was one who created Star
Wars but we're supposed to believe for
these groundbreaking fantastic films but
were only subsequently tainted by George
Lucas my point is this I think a lot of
people to understand that Star Wars was
always meant to be more so not entirely
but it was aimed at children or at least
more so that a lot of people now want to
I don't say give it credit for but
acknowledge like there was a guy was it
recently just he was crying at the new
Star Wars trailer and everyone was
making fun of this guy and I feel bad
for the kid like first time I think that
was a horrible choice to upload a medium
you crime to a trailer for a science
fiction film but here's why I'm not
gonna jump on the bandwagon and bully
that guy I remember people doing that at
the preview for the Phantom Menace okay
and it's become cool now to go there all
the Phantom Menace was terrible that is
not what people were saying when the
Phantom Menace came out came out comment
below and tell me if you remember this I
remember I had no idea why the theater
was packed I was seeing some other movie
incidentally in Canada I had no idea
this was the the premiere of the preview
for Phantom Menace and people were
gasping
and they were doing these interviews for
local television afterward with CBC
people this is the most amazing thing
I've ever seen in my life and then they
saw a Phantom Menace and for the first
few weeks I remember I went to go see it
because everyone convinced me that it
was awesome
and I saw it and I could only say this
now because the Star Wars fans have
retro actively made it okay to dislike
the Phantom Menace but that wasn't the
case back then I went back with my dad
and my brother we were in some way or an
upstate New York we went across the
border because we used to go there for
you know things like Old Navy and Taco
Bell cool stuff that we didn't have in
Canada at the time i don't know i'm not
i'm not sure about this Phantom Menace
but let me get my brother my dad to go
see and they laughed so hard in the
theater out loud that people were
shutting them they were fury and I mean
they were laughing out loud how crappy
it was like Jar Jar Binks and that that
character would everything that that
thing that's all I remember
podracing in some little some little bug
that had a big nose do you I'm talking
I'm talking about anyway we were
laughing so hard people got furious
because this movie meant so much and
they loved it and they were afterwards
someone audio he just you don't get it
no here's the thing with Star Wars some
people don't get it under understand it
I have people in my family who try and
you know hold it to the standard of
reality it's not it's a science fiction
film right it's fantasy but some people
do get it and do like it and some people
do get it and think that it's not great
filmmaking certainly not good writing
that's where I would consider myself
somebody who understands what Star Wars
is about I liked it when I was a kid the
original films when I went back and
watched them I didn't think they were I
didn't enjoy them as much as an adult
and when people complain about the newer
films being a licensing play or a
merchandising play and there's been kid
if I to say you know what however old
you are now go back and watch the
originals and tell me that there was a
little bit I think there was and you
comment below and let me know if you're
looking forward to this Star Wars film
if you're not another thing I don't
think Godfather's all
that's not anything I want politically
when I tell people I think Chinatown was
the better movie that year again I
challenge you go back and I I understand
you have to accept films for what they
aren't that purity in time go back and
watch Godfather and Chinatown and tell
me which ones better
and Road West you raped a kid right so
get that like I'm not I'm not saying
that wrong Polanski is I'm not his his
bud I'm not a fan I just think that
there's some sort of sacred cows out
there on the Roma film that you know
we're not allowed to touch on this case
maybe for some people torch um anyway
the Christmas show is tomorrow Wednesday
December 18th at 8 p.m. Eastern we're
gonna be live streaming and of course
here on YouTube 7 p.m. central code
Eventbrite search Crowder they'll find
it buy a ticket we'll have a good time
and let me know what you think about so
I'll go see what my nephew but I'll just
I'll enjoy it for what it is I'll be
watching my nephew watch Star Wars more
than I'll really care about the film and
that's I hope you guys if that's not a
slight to anyone who loves Star Wars
just you know it's my opinion and uh I'm
gonna dog